- There was a Black officer
who wanted to start
an organization,
an internal organization
where only Black people,
and then he would have
preferred only Black gay people
could come to a meeting, right.
So in other words, on government
property inside Langley
you had to be Black
and you had to be gay
in order to come
to those meetings.
Now, I don't even
know how many people
would fit the bill there,
maybe like seven or eight
so I'm not sure what you'd
have done at that meeting,
but nevertheless, the point is
there was this very clearly
discriminatory request
by an officer who should
have known better,
but he made the request and
the Office of General Counsel
had to come in and say, "No,
that is wildly inappropriate.
We're not doing that."
And he was actually livid.
I mean, he was livid
that he had to be told no
and to be reminded of the law.
So that kind of wokeism
stuff matched with, I think,
some of the PR stuff you see
coming out of the
CIA these days.
You may recall that young
woman in the Twitter video
saying that she was
a, what was this?
Was it bisexual or lesbian
Latina who has ADHD and-
- Oh, yeah, yeah. She had
a little of everything.
- She went through the
woke Olympics list.
So that, I'm sorry to say,
has really become
the younger culture.
And folks who are a little
bit older who came through,
I think the era,
frankly, of the '90s
such as yourself and myself,
the Gen Xers, we're like,
"Look, we don't
care who you are.
Just come in and do the work.
We want to treat
everybody with respect
and equal opportunity."
But it's now like you now
have to believe what I do.
And if you don't, you're a
bigot or a racist or homophobic,
et cetera, and that's new.
And that's only been in
the past five to 10 years,
really started under
the Obama years.
(energetic music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and joining me today
is a former CIA officer and
host of the new podcast,
"The President's Daily
Brief," Bryan Dean Wright.
Welcome back to
"The Rubin Report."
- Pleasure as always, my friend.
- Bryan, you've been
on a couple times.
I know you a bit
outside of the show.
I did not know you
were the President.
Is there something
I've been missing here?
- Well, I started first with
a local group of dog owners
as the president of that club
and I've moved all the way to
the White House in my mind.
And it's great, just me and Joe
and we're working
on Hunter's laptop.
It's gonna be all fixed up.
Don't you worry about that.
- "The President's Daily Brief."
That's the name of the show.
You have a real
pedigree in the CIA
that I want to talk about
for people that have not seen
some of your other
appearances on my show.
I wanna recap some of that
stuff, but let's just,
just off the name
of the new show,
"The President's Daily Brief."
Now, I'm not a big
believer in this guy.
Something does not seem
right with this guy.
I'm starting to think this
guy may not be in charge.
Is this your way
of kinda getting in
and in case something happens
saying, "Hey, I'm here,
I've got the title of
the show, et cetera"?
- I wasn't thinking about that,
but now that you mention it,
yes, and I'm ready to serve
because let's be honest,
Kamala is number two and
that's also a hot mess.
And then we got Pelosi. We
all know where that's going.
So yeah, it's me. I'm ready.
- It's you, it's you.
All right, for people
that don't know you,
we'll link to the
original interview below
if they want the full recap,
but can you just give me
a little of the Bryan
Dean Wright 101,
a little bit of your
history in the CIA?
And then also we have a sort
of similar political path
that we should get
into a bit as well.
- You bet, yeah, so I began
my career with the CIA
just after the 9/11 attacks.
It was October of 2001.
You know, we were all panicked
as we all started
our young careers.
As folks who love this country,
we had just been
hit in the face.
Nobody quite knew
exactly who, when,
and where abroad that we
might be hit from next.
So that really kicked off
my career at the agency,
and I was there for a
good number of years
focused on weapons of mass
destruction, counter-terrorism.
As most of us did, focused
a little bit in Asia.
I can't get in particulars,
and then also in Africa
and it was an amazing
career and I had a great,
great time doing it
and been fortunate
to actually teach the next cadre
or next generation
of officers as well.
So I've had a really,
really fun career.
And then towards the
very end, got introduced
to a few different
people to include you
and had a great opportunity
that was just by lucky
happenstance to start talking
about different
issues in the world,
particularly national security.
And here we are with a podcast
and I'm really excited.
- How tough is it to
make that transition?
Because CIA, you
gotta be somebody
that can't drop all the
secrets all the time.
And then next thing you know,
you're talking on
camera, doing a podcast.
- Yeah.
- How do you blend
those two things?
- Spend 20 years avoiding
cameras and attention.
And now here I am,
it's an odd transition.
You know, I think if
you talk to anybody
who has really been
a true operator,
they understand the
importance of being anonymous.
You know, unlike,
let's say, a James Bond
or those characters, the idea
isn't you go into somewhere
and you start blowing stuff up.
The idea is you go
in, you're very quiet.
You're discreet. You
do what you need to do.
And then you leave and
actually no one ever knows.
So if you're pointing out
a gun or tossing a bomb,
something's gone
pretty wrong, right?
But the idea of then
sitting in front of a camera
and engaging people
yes, was absolutely odd.
But I will tell you
that in many ways,
the job has a lot of parallels
in that if you do it well,
and if you do it right,
and with all, truly,
I think you're one of them.
You really can capture
people's hearts and minds
and you can move people.
And I think with intelligence,
you can do that with your
listeners or your viewers,
that you know, if you're
briefing the President, right,
so the president's daily
brief is an actual brief
given to the President of the
United States every morning
by our spies and analysts.
And you can capture the
President's attention,
not only with what's
happening in the world,
but how do we solve the problems
and why he or she should
care about those problems.
So I think in that sense,
there are some parallels,
and I'm really excited to
bring that kind of background
to this podcast and bring
listeners that same focus,
that same piece of critical
information every morning.
- So I actually wanna talk
about the real president's brief
that you just mentioned as
well as whether you think Joe
is actually reading it,
or whether they even
bother handing it to him
or even if they're
printing it at this point.
But putting that
aside for a second,
it struck me as you were saying
that that if five years ago,
and I had you on probably
maybe three or four years ago,
but if let's say five
or even seven years ago,
I had had a former CIA officer
on, my feeling about the CIA
as an institution
would be very different
than it is right now, and I
think a lot of people feel that.
And it's not with any
great pleasure I say that.
I suspect for you with
a lot of displeasure.
- Yeah.
- Can you talk about what
has sort of happened
to the agencies?
Like we see this woke thing
infecting absolutely everything.
I mean, the CIA, the
FBI, the military,
they're tweeting
about woke stuff
more than seemingly doing
whatever it is that
they are supposed to do,
even if we're not supposed
to know all that stuff.
- Right, so, man, I'll tell
you that there are two things
that I think folks should
really be focusing on.
The first is the weaponization
of the intelligence community.
You know, we knew back in
May of 2017 James Comey,
the FBI director at the time
acknowledged that he
had leaked sensitive,
classified information to a
cutout to "The New York Times"
with the only goal of basically
hammering Donald Trump,
getting a new special counsel
to investigate the Russia
collusion allegations.
Now, Comey knew back then,
and unfortunately we
were only learning
in the last number of years
that that was garbage, right?
So we saw that in the FBI.
We later saw it with a
guy named Kevin Clinesmith
who was this very
senior FBI official
who'd falsified evidence to
a court to get surveillance
or continue surveillance
on Carter Page.
So I think that had you
told me that seven years ago
that that was in the realm
of possible, I would've,
to be honest with you,
I would've laughed
you outta the room
because what I knew to be
true is that we had people
who were committed
to the rule of law,
whether it be the
FBI or the CIA.
We were committed to our
oaths to be non-political,
apolitical, certainly
when we walked
through those front doors and
we were focused on mission,
but that has been completely
and utterly annihilated.
That is to say, my belief that
the intelligence community
and the FBI are not
political, they are.
We have proof. We have evidence.
It's painful because at the
very moment that we are facing
this massive
challenge with China,
this huge issue with Russia,
we actually need a really good,
healthy, functional
intelligence community
and law enforcement community.
And on the federal level,
we just, we don't have it.
I can't tell you or
the folks watching
that they've got the kind of
government that they deserve
because I don't
think that they do.
- Do you know when
that started there?
'Cause now we're seeing
it more obviously,
but it didn't just start
because they started tweeting
about this stuff six
months ago, obviously.
- Yeah, well, I'll tell
you, I think candidly,
politics aside, I think
during the Obama years,
you started seeing a lot
of people misunderstanding
that they were there to be
of service to their country.
And instead those agencies
and ultimately their country
is supposed to be
of service to them.
I mean, Jack Kennedy said it
very famously many decades ago.
That started to change,
I think, culturally
in the Obama years because
it was really about me.
It was about the self, my
truth and celebrating that.
And so we went, I think,
from in the early 2000s
when people were
saying very clearly,
"Look, it doesn't matter
if you're gay or straight
or Christian or Muslim
or Black and White.
Just come in and be of service.
Leave your politics
at the door."
So that was, I think, where
most of us would be, is to say,
yeah, get the equal opportunity
that's focused on mission.
And now it's become,
instead of mission
or really at the same
level of mission,
tell me what you're
passionate about,
what your interests are.
Like, tell me your
story and your truth,
the stuff that's not
mission critical,
but it's being treated as such.
And I can tell a couple
of amazing stories
on the inside of the agency
about how the racial woke
piece is really detrimental
or playing a profoundly
detrimental role
in mission criticalness.
- Give me one of those.
- All right, so there
was an individual whose-
- Pick one, any one.
- Yeah, a lot of
'em, unfortunately.
There was a Black officer
who wanted to start
an organization,
an internal organization
where only Black people,
and then he would have
preferred only Black gay people
could come to a meeting, right.
So in other words, on government
property inside Langley
you had to be Black
and you had to be gay
in order to come
to those meetings.
Now, I don't even
know how many people
would even fit the bill there,
maybe like seven or eight
so I'm not sure what you
would've done at that meeting,
but nevertheless, the point is
there was this very clearly
discriminatory request
by an officer who should
have known better,
but he made the request and
the Office of General Counsel
had to come in and say, "No,
that is wildly inappropriate.
We're not doing that."
And he was actually livid.
I mean, he was livid
that he had to be told no
and to be reminded of the law.
So that kind of wokeism
stuff matched with, I think,
some of the PR stuff you see
coming out of the
CIA these days.
You may recall that young woman
in the Twitter video saying
that she was a, what was this?
Was it bisexual or lesbian
Latina who has ADHD-
- Oh, yeah, yeah. She had
a little of everything.
- She went through the
woke Olympics list.
So that, I'm sorry to say
has really become
the younger culture.
And, you know, folks who
are a little bit older
who came through, I think
the era, frankly, of the '90s
such as yourself and myself,
that the Gen Xers, we're like,
"Look, we don't
care who you are.
Just come in and do the work.
We want to treat
everybody with respect
and equal opportunity."
But it's now like, you now
have to believe what I do.
And if you don't, you're a
bigot or a racist or homophobic,
et cetera, and that's new.
And that's only been in
the past five to 10 years,
really started under
the Obama years.
- Are you shocked
that the institutions
didn't have better
defenses against this?
I've asked this to many guests
from many different disciplines,
usually at the education
level that you'd think
that some of the STEM subjects
would've had better defenses.
People are like, all right,
yeah, of course, you know,
lesbian dance theory was
gonna go down, but you know,
math perhaps or biology,
that should have been okay,
but now we're seeing
it across there.
Are you surprised that
our actual, I mean,
these are our most highest
elite security services now
are going down that
they did not have
some fail safe in there?
- Look, am I surprised? Yeah.
I think most people in
this country right now
are not just surprised
but shocked, right?
I think most people
want to be reasonable
and want to be compassionate
about welcoming different
people into their families
and to their communities.
But we're seeing that go well
beyond any degree of reason.
And so I think the
CIA, you're seeing it,
a reflection of what
people are experiencing
outside of Langley in
their own families,
in their own communities.
They're feeling that
pressure to sort of conform.
And then they're being
told from the top down
from the President's
office, him or herself,
you have to do this.
And they're like, well,
I'm not gonna be fired
so I guess I have
to go along with it.
And that's what I
think you're seeing.
Even the very, very smart,
very critical thinking people
are starting to
fall into this trap
because they're gonna lose
their job if they don't.
- When you saw the
51, I believe it was,
former intelligence
officers who all said
that the Hunter Biden laptop
was Russian misinformation
or disinformation,
they all said it
without having seen it, okay?
When you saw that.
So let's go back before
it's been debunked,
but when it originally came out,
I'm talking during the election,
when they all came
out and said that,
conveniently enough,
right before the election.
What was your take
then compared to now?
- Hmm, hmm, both then and
now my reaction was the same.
There is absolutely
no way to know
unless you do a
forensic analysis
of whether or not that laptop,
A, belonged to Hunter Biden
and B, if there was any
additional information added
that would be thus
disinformation or propaganda
or part of some sort of covert
action op by the Russians,
the Chinese,
whoever it might be.
So to immediately come out and
just dismiss it was absurd.
And what it showed me
was that those people on
that list were partisans.
They were using the stink, as
it were, of working at the CIA
being an intelligence
officer to go out
to the American people with
some degree of gravitas,
like they're sort of mini James
Bond or whoever it might be
and so you're gonna
take them seriously.
And so they abused their
professional histories
to make this partisan point.
And so again, we
saw this by the way,
not just with the
Hunter Biden laptop.
We saw this with
the Steele dossier.
That's perhaps even more
egregious years prior to that,
when I think you could
say, where's a point
where we really started
seeing this publicly.
You had a whole bunch of
intelligence officials
who damn well know better
that when you get information
which was what was
inside the Steele dossier
which is from Russia, right,
that you had to tread
very, very cautiously
around Russian intel
because of the likelihood
that it has been
fed, in this case,
to Steele, the British spy.
So when you had people saying,
"Oh, the Steele dossier is
true, it's gotta be true."
That's when I was like,
all right, this whole
thing has been cooked.
This is absolutely
members of the IC
wanting to be part of the
Hillary Clinton administration
or the Joe Biden
administration now
who are trying to gain favor
and they're using their
backgrounds to do so.
And it's just infuriating
because ultimately what happens
and what has happened is that
the American people lose faith
in the intelligence community.
They lose faith in the
law enforcement community.
And rightfully so.
And so when that happens, you've
got a whole bunch of people
with lots of profound powers
who don't actually have the
support of American people.
They start acting basically
with impunity because they can.
Countries start falling apart
when this stuff happens.
And that's the part that
I'm so profoundly afraid of.
- Right, so I try not to be a
crazy alarmist on this show.
Try, maybe I fail at
it, but I try not to be,
but it seems to me that's
kind of where we're at
because when the 51
intelligence officers,
in essence, former-
- Propagandists.
- Propagandists. I
was trying to be nice.
Thank you for cleaning
that up for me.
- Yeah, you don't have-
- When those 51 propagandists
were exposed as such,
meaning "The New York Times"
finally a year and a half
later, everyone knows this now,
a month and a half ago
or so finally said,
"Yeah, yeah, the laptop
was real, by the way."
Did anyone get called
into an office?
Did anyone get fired from
a consulting gig they got?
Did anyone get fired from a
lobbying firm or anything?
I suspect not, and that goes
to your point about the trust.
It's like, I think
they sort of feel
like can get away with anything
'cause they can get
away with anything.
- Yeah, well, and there was
a report out sometime back
that the Joe Biden
administration has
actually encouraged
and allowed this junk intel
to go out about Ukraine
all because he wants to try to
encourage the American people
to embrace a greater
involvement in the war.
So you are having
this intelligence
fiasco after fiasco.
And at some level, I
think a reasonable person
says, "I've had enough.
Whenever you say 'American
intelligence assesses,'
I'm not gonna believe it."
And I can't tell those
people right now,
particularly with the current
leadership that they're wrong.
And that's really sad for a
guy who spent most of his life
in the world of intelligence.
- Let's shift that a little bit
to what you just
mentioned there.
So this Russia-Ukraine
situation,
I actually have not covered
it a ton on the show.
I was very honest with my
audience from the beginning.
I was kind of like, this whole
thing reads very weird to me,
the whole setup, the
Biden laptop piece of it.
Suddenly we all gotta
hate Russia. I'm not
defending Russia.
You can't just invade
a sovereign nation,
but it just felt like
so much propaganda
that I've bounced
around it a little bit.
And I've talked about
the after-affects
meaning inflation and
gas and things like that.
And I've tried to talk
about what we should do
perhaps and should do,
but I'm not doing the daily
thing with Russia and Ukraine.
How are you able to assess
information properly?
Because I think people
are just, you know,
you put the Ukrainian flag
in your Twitter avatar.
Everybody else is an
evil Nazi, that's it.
I suspect it's not
quite that simple.
- Oh dear. No.
So you know that you're
caught in a hysteria when,
and this is true, both
of the major marathons
in this country have banned
runners from Ukraine or Russia,
or I should say Russia or
Belorussia from running, right?
So we're banning
marathon runners-
- Yeah, not Ukraine,
not Ukraine.
- Because of their
national identity, right?
And we're pouring out, you know,
we're renaming chicken
Kiev and it's chicken Kyiv.
Stop, all right. This
is hysteria defined.
So I think that it's important
for people like me to speak
to these issues
around war and peace
and including in Ukraine
knowing that there is
a fog of war issue.
So when I talk about
Ukraine or any other places
around the world, I'm gonna
be very careful to make sure
that I have medium or
high degree of confidence
in what I'm sharing with people.
Now, this issue of confidence
is one that is very familiar
to anybody who's worked in
the intelligence community.
You don't put out to
policy makers or the public
low-confidence information.
Low-confidence information means
that you haven't vetted
it or the person, right?
You haven't compared that report
that that spy is giving you
to maybe you've captured
an email or a phone call
or you've gotten other spies
who are confirming
the same information.
So in other words, there's
this issue of confidence.
You want to give policy
makers medium to high degree
of confidence in
your assessments.
I do that the same, I had that
same focus, that same spirit
when I talk about the things
on "The President's
Daily Brief" the podcast,
and that's what the intelligence
community should be doing
right now on the issues
of Ukraine and others.
But that's not what's happening.
Again, this report that came
out not too terribly long ago
that confirmed the
Biden administration
is putting out
low-confidence intel,
gossip, rumors to
the American press
about what's happening
in the Ukraine.
Example, the story that Russia
was going to utilize chemical
or biological weaponry,
that story came out
in February into March.
There was actually
no intelligence
that said that
that would happen.
Now it could still in the future
or perhaps as we're
speaking, it just has.
But the point is at the moment
when they gave that story
to the American people and
to the world, it wasn't true.
So when you start doing that,
when you start just pumping
out low-confidence information,
information that's probably
just gossip and rumors,
you do this horrible thing
of undermining confidence
in the intelligence community.
And oh, by the way,
Dave, we did this before.
Do you remember in the
run-up in the war of Iraq,
we started that war because of
weapons of mass destruction.
That was the story that
was sold to people.
We had low confidence that
that was true, by the way.
It was based on one guy.
The operation was Curveball.
And Curveball was
a big old liar.
And it was the responsibility
of the intelligence
community to vet that person,
their information to say,
nope, that was a lie.
- But didn't Colin Powell
say there was a rod?
I thought Colin Powell
went in front of Congress
and said he saw a
rod or something.
- Yeah, yeah, sure.
Well, I'm sure they
all saw lots of things
after they were wrong,
namely their retirements.
- Yeah.
- But the issue is, so now
the intelligence community,
when I was at the CIA, we
all were burned by that case.
And we said to each other,
particularly the analysts,
"Never again, never again
are we going to be allowed
to pump out low-confidence
garbage intel into the world
because we're gonna get
ourselves in trouble again.
We're gonna cause
trillion dollar wars
with hundreds of thousands
of people dead like in Iraq
or thousands and thousands
of our soldiers and airmen
and the rest who come
home without arms
and legs and their
minds are broken."
That's the legacy of
putting out garbage intel,
and Joe Biden is doing
it again in the Ukraine.
- What do you make
of what I would argue
is the absolutely extraordinary
level of incompetence
of this administration when
it comes to the messaging.
So for example, when
just a couple weeks ago,
there was suddenly this rumor
that they were gonna use,
Russia was gonna use
chemical weapons,
I did not bother
saying a word about it
'cause it just felt
nonsensical to me
because why wouldn't you in a
war of propaganda just be like
"Yeah, the other guy is
gonna use chemical weapons."
That's a pretty good move
But then Joe Biden
was asked a question
about chemical
weapons and he said,
"If he uses them,
we'll respond in kind."
Now, I don't think he has
the greatest understanding
of what he's saying
on any given moment,
especially when it's
completely off prompter,
but that everything they say,
we did an incredible
compilation on my show
a couple weeks ago
of the mixed messaging
related to sanctions.
Sanctions will stop them.
Sanctions do nothing.
Sanctions do a little.
Sanctions do a lot.
Everybody from the
President to Psaki to Kamala
to the whole crew just saying
every version of everything.
- Yeah, well, you
were highlighting
the inconsistencies.
The American people see the
inconsistencies and that's why
at this present moment, Joe
Biden's approval numbers
are about those of a really
bad case of hemorrhoids.
And so it makes sense
that the American people,
they see through it,
we all see through it.
And it ultimately, beyond
the political ramifications
for the rest of this
year, for instance,
and the run-up to the
midterm elections,
it also has profound
implications
in terms of our relationships
with people abroad.
Because for instance,
when we start sharing bits
and pieces of intelligence,
is that really true?
And we're asking these countries
to do things on our behalf
because of this
intelligence, right?
So that's the cost from our
national security perspective
when they're putting
out bogus information
or they're putting out stuff
that's even inconsistent
with their own values.
So if Joe Biden says that
we're gonna respond in kind
with chemical weaponry, are
they gonna pause and say,
"Well, we don't want to
hitch our nation's wagon
to this country
America right now
'cause it's being led by a
crazy person who obviously
is mentally incapacitated
to some degree
and clearly is not able
to make good decisions
or can't even put out the
right words to do so."
So there's pretty serious
national security ramifications
to his mumblings,
and we all see it.
It's reflected in the approval
numbers, but I guarantee you
in capitals around the world
right now, they see it too.
- How do we reverse
some of this stuff?
Because okay, we could all
say, all right, the errors
always seem to be in
the Democrats' favor
or the leaks are always
to "The New York Times"
in the favor of the Democrats,
et cetera, et cetera.
But this isn't just okay,
elect more Republicans
and you're gonna save the
intelligence services, right?
I mean, what is the solution?
- Well, you know, I mentioned
Jack Kennedy earlier.
He has a pretty famous quote
that I love and I embrace.
And it's, "When we
seek out solutions,
let us not seek the
Democratic answer
or the Republican answer,
but the right answer."
And I think that most reasonable
people in this country
understand that that's
really how you should govern
and that's how you should
lead your own families.
Not necessarily in
terms of your politics,
but you look for the
right way to do things
based on reasoned and
critical thinking.
So the issue then is
at this moment in time,
do we have two parties or two
movements or another party
that we're not considering
beyond the Democrats,
Republicans who are committed
to critical thinking
to reason, or is one of them
just so wildly off the mark
that we just have to
say, look, for right now,
those people are too crazy.
And that for me, that
decision was very obvious.
About a year ago, I
left the Democrat Party,
I became a Republican
not because of any
profound affection
or affinity for
Republicanism in general,
although I've always
been a conservative,
but the point is we
actually have people
on the left right now,
the Democrat Party,
which I've been a part
of for a long time,
was, my family who were saying,
"Critical thinking's
bad," right?
Reason is bad. Why?
Because those are things
that White people
do and White is bad.
That's not hyperbole, by the
way. They're saying this.
You know this. You've spoken
about this eloquently.
So if that's part of the
answer that people are,
when they have to go to the
ballot box and they're saying,
"Okay, do I wanna
elect the people
who don't think that reason
or critical thinking
is a good thing?
In fact, it's a bad
thing 'cause it's White."
Like, no, it doesn't even matter
what the rest of
their solutions are.
Those people are crazy, and
I'm not going to vote for them.
Now, you very, again, eloquently
talk about that the left
is, mentally bonker, they're
mentally ill, and that's true.
The party is full
of these folks.
And because they are so full
of these sort of panicked,
hysterical ways of thinking
that they're not responsible
enough to govern.
There are some Democrats
still who are reasonable,
but they choose to
be quiet, right?
Some of the blue dogs, for
instance, they have chosen
to just be quiet, to
go along to get along.
And that's just
not enough, right?
I mean, there aren't
enough of them
and they certainly aren't
speaking up to say,
"Yep, all right, there
are crazy elements,
but I'm gonna give 'em a shot."
'Cause those people
are not in leadership
and they never will be.
- So that's exactly why
I said at the beginning
that we've had similar
political evolutions
because you were a
Democrat most of your life.
And you've probably heard
me say it, but my new line
that I've been saying for
about a year and a half now is,
you don't have to
be a Republican,
but you cannot be a Democrat.
That seems like the
honest assessment.
It does not mean that
these guys are right,
and they screw up an
awful lot of stuff.
- Yeah.
- But as AOC said, "You don't
have to be factually right.
You have to be morally correct."
That is some dangerous,
dangerous stuff.
- Yeah, well, it's reflective
of her political movement,
which is not liberalism, it's
Marxism and she's very clear,
although she hides it on
occasion or dresses it up
in TikTok dance videos
to make people think
that it's cute and fun, but
you are absolutely right.
You have called this
out consistently,
and folks watching know that
that is absolutely the truth
because we have eyes and ears
and we listen to people
on the left right now.
The video that went
around sometime back of,
I think it was Dennis Prager
who went on the Bill Maher show
a number of years ago and
was talking about this idea
of sort of the trans movement.
And that right now a
bunch of people are saying
that men can menstruate.
And what was so interesting
is of course that Bill Maher
and others were laughing
at him at the absurdity
that anybody would
propose such a thing.
But it was also that
the audience, the
audience was laughing
at the suggestion that
men could menstruate.
They all thought it was
just this absurd thing
these crazy right wing
people are saying,
but it turns out he was
right both then and now.
And other people were
making this argument, look,
not only are you telling
us that we can't think,
or we can't think for ourselves
or can't think critically
or with reason, but now
you're actually telling us
to abandon basic
biology, basic facts.
And so the question is why,
why are you having us do this?
Because this is crazy.
And so politically speaking,
you're gonna start
losing a lot of people
who otherwise identify as
Democrats or moderate Democrats.
Even some progressives
that I've talked to,
and I'm sure you have
as well, they're like,
"Okay, I don't know where
this is going or it came from,
but this is really weird."
They want to be embracing all
kinds of different people,
and they want to create
a lovely opportunity
for folks to excel in life.
But this stuff of the magic
closet where teachers right now
are telling trans
kids that they can go
into the secret closet
with the teacher
and swap out their clothes
but don't tell mom and dad.
I mean, come on.
That's ridiculous.
That kind of stuff,
that's creepy.
It is grooming behavior and
it's wildly inappropriate.
- Yeah, and people are more
upset with the label grooming
than actually what's going on
in the freaking secret closet.
And to your point
about Dennis Prager,
that was probably a
year and a half ago.
And you know, just in
the last couple weeks
we confirmed a Supreme Court
justice who isn't a biologist
so she has no freaking
clue what the difference
between a male and a female is.
But, okay, so if someone's
listening to this
and they're like, "All right,
I won't vote for Democrats,
at least for now, I'll
vote for Republicans."
So now we get all
the Republicans in.
We get the red wave
that I pray will happen
because we need it,
at least for now,
what will they do that will
fix the intelligence agencies?
I mean, what really is that?
Are we just cleaning
house firing, you know,
you hear some people, "Just
fire everybody or close it."
But I mean, I hear
people talking about,
just close 'em all and
just get rid of everybody.
- Yeah, well look,
I think all options
have to be on the table.
And I think that you
have to understand
that within the Department
of Defense, the FBI, the CIA,
and the NSA, there is a history
of doing a pretty profound
sort of investigation,
as it were,
panels on the House
Intelligence Select Committees.
There was a Church
Committee back in the 1970s
when there were all
kinds of horrible things
in the intelligence
community the CIA was doing.
They had these conversations
where they said,
"Look, you guys
are outta control,
and here's what we
need to do to fix it."
So in other words, let's
acknowledge there's a problem.
And then let's talk about
how we fix the problem.
And I think that that's
where you need to start.
And I think Republicans
would be very, very wise
in both the House and the
Senate to have those series
of investigative
conversations, those panels,
those committee conversations,
and probably many months long
where you just start
airing some dirty laundry
inside the intel community,
some of the bad things
that they would
probably otherwise,
you know, they don't
want us to know about.
Put it out there and
let's have some solutions
based on how bad the rod is.
This is happening, by
the way, in the military,
They're becoming
super woke as well.
I've had the great fortune
of working with folks
in the military for a
good number of years.
They see it, too. I've
seen it too there.
So this is broad and we need
to have some really
good oversight diving
into this issue.
It's not just the woke stuff.
It's, how did it
start? Who embraces it?
Moving those people who
aren't focused on mission
and then rising
other individuals up
into positions of
authority and influence
who I don't care if they're
Republican or Democrat,
conservative or
liberal, whatever.
they have an exclusive
understanding of mission, right?
A faithful commitment
to law and order,
and that they take an oath
and they understand
what that means.
And that is to be of service
to the American people
and to the mission and
they leave politics behind.
That's what has
to be reinstilled
into the intelligence
community, FBI,
the CIA, NSA, and
also our military.
How do you do that? You
gotta remove some people.
Unquestionably,
that's gonna happen.
Do you look at folding the FBI?
I'm open not to collapsing
the entirety of it,
but if you wanna
shift the mission,
different parts of the
national security division,
for instance, to other
places, let's talk about it.
I don't know what
the solution is,
but we need dramatic
and complete reform.
- What I always think sits
behind a conversation like this,
and I've had this type of
conversation with you before,
and I've had it
with other people
and you've obviously had it
with tons and tons of
other people is like,
are you afraid to talk
about some of this stuff?
Like, don't they put the
the drop in the drink
when you're looking
the wrong way
or the litany of weird things
or drop information on you
or smear you or go to "The
New York Times" and lie?
I mean, the litany of things
that they can do to anybody
in a time, especially when
it's fueled by algorithms
and a media that's not an
honest arbiter of truth.
I mean, you're saying
some pretty, you know,
it's some scary stuff that
obviously some powerful people
will not be thrilled to hear.
- Yeah, well, not to
be cliched about this,
but if you remember at
founding in this country,
when someone asked, I believe
it was Benjamin Franklin,
what kind of government that he
and the rest of the Founding
Fathers and mothers gave us,
his response was "A republic,
if you can keep it," right?
So explicit in that response,
from the very foundation
of our government is,
you have to get in there,
roll up your sleeves
and get dirty.
And unfortunately that
getting dirty sometimes
can be somebody sullying in
your reputation at worst,
or doing you physical
harm, or should say best
and doing you physical
harm at worst.
So yeah, I mean, has it
crossed my mind? Sure.
Is it possible that
there'll be some sort
of deep AI smear campaign?
Yeah, of course, and in
fact, I think it's gonna hit
not just truth tellers,
people who speak up
and tell the American people
what's really going on,
but I think you're
also gonna see
different politicians
be hit by that.
That warning has been out
for a number of years.
So I absolutely think
that it's possible,
maybe not on an official
basis, but former officers
who might not like
me could decide
to do little shenanigans,
you know, sure.
But my bottom line to anyone
who's worrying about that is,
if we live in fear, we
will be ruled by it.
So I'm not gonna live in
fear. I know who I am.
I know I'm a good man.
I'm not a perfect man.
And if it is such that
I end up getting hit
or smeared by something,
then by God, so be it.
Then somebody else is
gonna pick up the flag
and they're gonna
grab that thing
keep running forward
because this place
is exceptional.
This country is exceptional.
It's worth fighting for.
It is imperfect, but it's
our job to make it better,
and I'm not going
to be ruled by fear.
And I don't think people
like you are either.
And what's awesome about people
like you with your voice,
people putting out incredible
books like you are,
you're telling people
don't live in fear either.
Find alternatives, keep
pushing and do not stop
because this place
is worth saving.
- That should be
the end of the show,
but we still got some more time,
but that was a beautiful
opus to end this thing on.
Now you've put a lot
of pressure on yourself
to end this thing properly.
- Someone gimme a Lincoln
speech. I don't know. (laughs)
- Since we're sort
of bouncing around
with a whole bunch of stuff here
so let's just keep going then.
When it comes to the way
the intelligence community
deals with media
and with big tech,
what should we be thinking
about, worrying about?
So if we just back up
again to the Biden laptop,
it wasn't just the 51 CIA
and intelligence officials.
It was also that
Twitter got in on it.
So it's like, why has
nobody said to Twitter,
"Hey, who decided that?
Did you guys have a meeting?
Is there an email record of
that? Maybe a calendar invite?"
- Yeah, so is the
ultimate question,
how the heck do we get
a lasso on big tech
and make sure that they are
sticking to what they should be,
which is a provider
of opportunities
to share speech versus censors?
There are very smart people
working on this issue.
You are one with Locals
and other great solutions,
and I think that's what you do.
You start building your own
infrastructure to reach people.
And that's gonna take time.
That's gonna take a lot of
effort and a lot of money.
I think we're
starting to see people
who might not necessarily
be an ideological partner
in some ways, but
guys like Elon Musk
who are stepping up to
the plate and saying,
"Hey, here are my resources not
because I love conservatives
or liberals, but damn it,
there should be a platform
for people to speak truth
or their version of it.
And the answer to crazy
talk is more sane talk."
And that's always been the
actual liberal position.
You've talked about this.
That's the classic
liberal position
that has been
abandoned by the left,
and they've embraced tyranny
and censorship, you know?
So I think that it is more of us
recognizing what's happening
and more people with influence,
people like you, people
with money like Elon Musk
finding market solutions
to this problem.
And then it's about next fall.
God willing,
conservatives take over.
No matter if you
agree or disagree
on some of the other
party platform positions,
this has to be a central one.
And so when you go to vote,
you make it very clear
to the person you're voting
for in whatever way you do
that look, I might not
otherwise have voted for you,
but this is an important issue
to me, this censorship stuff.
It's really about our
constitutional rights.
They're under assault, fix it.
And maybe I'll
vote for you again.
I don't know, but you deserve
one shot to get this right
because it's an
existential problem
and it's important to me.
- You mean you don't
necessarily deserve 60 years
in the Senate like
some of these people
or in the House or
whatever they're doing?
Not the senators, but
the people in the House
that are there forever.
Nancy Pelosi's been there 87
years, something like that.
- Yeah.
- It's just, it never ends.
Can you talk a little
bit about generally
how in politics
secrets remain secrets?
Or things like, for example,
things that we can see
that we all can kind of
see with our own eyes
that somehow just
never get discussed.
So the Biden cognitive
stuff, it's obvious.
Everyone knows it.
Every single person
that you mentioned to,
you talk about it privately,
everyone will admit
something is not right there,
but no one's allowed to
talk about it on mainstream.
It's never brought up.
Meanwhile, if Trump was
slurring every one of his words
and making up stories
and having these blips
that just go completely awry,
we woulda 25th Amendment-ed
him seven times ago.
So what do we do?
- Yeah.
- How does that happen,
I guess is the question.
- Well, I think we-
- Not what do we do.
I have some ideas.
I just said of them,
25th Amendment.
- Yeah. (laughs).
Look, I think you can look
back in American history.
There have been times when
the media has stepped in
to hide a deficiency
of a leader.
So I'm thinking of Roosevelt
and some of his
physical challenges
being in a wheelchair
and so forth
so it's not unprecedented.
The issue is, why are we hiding?
That is to say, why is the
press hiding this thing
that might otherwise be bad
or perceived as
bad in the world?
You know, for Roosevelt,
it was about, you know,
would people view him as weak
if he couldn't stand up on
his own two feet, right?
But otherwise his mind, his
decision-making processes,
the ability to surround
himself with smart people
and make good decisions
for the country,
that was never in doubt.
So it was more of a, this is
a private matter that made him
sort of look less manly perhaps.
It was wrong, of course.
He was just as
manly as he was ever
in a wheelchair or otherwise,
but at the time that
was kind of the logic.
It was a bit more of
a genteel approach
to a personal problem, right?
But that's not the case anymore.
The press is basically
serving as the mouthpiece
for different
politicians, right?
So it's, I don't want
this embarrassing thing
about their infidelity or
their cognitive impairment
or the fact that
they've taken on
whatever degree of
corruption, right?
Their insider trading
with stocks, et cetera.
So now the press
knows those things.
And if the person who's
created or engaged in the sin,
for lack of a better word,
I'm gonna hide it because
they're on my team, right?
So the press has
become part of a team.
And when you have that,
and the data, by the
way, supports that,
we know that for
instance, that the press
gives overwhelmingly
to Democrats anywhere,
depending on the poll you
look at 83, 85% to 95 98%,
no matter where you
look, it's overwhelming.
- [Dave] Yeah, yeah.
- So they've chosen a team
and are hiding the bad stuff
that their team engages in.
That's what's different
as compared to what's
happened historically.
So how do you change that.
You just keep calling it about,
and the American people see it.
And what's happening is
they're starting to gravitate
to voices that they think
are more reasonable.
So mainstream media's
being challenged
by sort of smaller
voices, but that's great.
It's a marketplace of ideas.
It allows really, really smart
people, yourself and others
to stand up and say, "Hey, look,
listen, here's my own bias.
I'm gonna admit it,
unlike some of the people
in mainstream media, I'm gonna
tell you what my biases are
and where I've come from as
Bryan as a former Democrat,
now Republican conservative.
Like, you know
that on the table.
I'm not hiding any of that.
So let me present
to you the material.
I'm gonna offer
you my reflection.
And then you can decide
what to do with it
or add it to other voices."
I think that's what's going
to just naturally happen
and is already happening.
- Are there any countries
or security services,
information services that are
doing it significantly better?
Like if we get the
right people in,
is there anyone we can look
at that is doing it right?
And we could be like,
"Hey, borrow the manual
that they have over there."
- No, I'm sorry to say that
this issue of the politicization
of media is widespread,
it's across the country.
And it's been bad in lots
of places for a long time.
And I don't think
anybody's got it right,
anybody's doing it
well, unfortunately,
so that means that
we have to come up
with the set of solutions.
And I think we're gonna
try different things here
and something's gonna work
and some things won't,
and that's all right, but I
think at the end of the day,
my hope, and you hate
to base a plan on this,
is that there are gonna be
enough people in journalism
and the owners and the
editors who are like,
"Look, we're losing
audience share,
and they're going
to other places
and listening to other people
because we are such
partisan folks.
And so we are incentivized,
advertisers like us
because we've started
to gravitate back
to just Cronkite-like
news, right?
I would love to think
that that's possible.
I don't know that
it's gonna happen here
because most of us click or
are attracted to media outlets
and personalities who
reaffirm our own biases.
So I don't know what's
gonna break that fever,
but until it does-
- What about on the
intelligence side?
I'm with you on the media side,
but are there any countries
here, this hemisphere,
the other hemisphere,
maybe on another planet,
is someone doing
this somewhat okay?
- So I'll tell you,
I think that a lot of
that is pretty close hold
so I don't know the extent to
which it's being rooted out.
What I do know is that
in other countries,
if they find that, there is
no real publicizing that.
They end up just
disappearing people, right?
They sort of clean
house in that sense.
So unfortunately there is
no good path, but again,
I would go back to the fact
what we did in the 1970s,
when the CIA got so outta whack,
we dealt with it publicly,
and then we had reforms.
And so we did it before.
And I think we can do it
again with thoughtful people
who understand that
the problem is real.
That's the actual issue.
Right now you have
people in Congress
who don't think
the issue is real,
that we don't have a politicized
intelligence community
or a politicized law
enforcement community.
Some of them believe
that privately,
but they're not willing to
do anything about it publicly
because the FBI or the CIA
has been on their side, right?
You remember the
Democratic congressman
who was gonna give a job to
the disgraced FBI official
who'd done good things
for the Democrats.
Like, that's the kind of stuff
that you have to
remove those people,
put in good people in
your House and your Senate
who are focused on the country.
And then you have these
panels, these investigations,
you come up with reforms
and you get it done.
We've done it before.
We can do it again.
- Usually when they screw
up or lie to Congress,
they just get a job on CNN.
- Right. (laughs)
Touche, yeah.
- That's generally how it works.
Bryan, I suspect a
political future for you.
I don't know that
you suspect one,
and I thought you were
gonna make that very face,
but I suspect one.
- You know, well, okay,
look, that's very kind.
Seriously, I mean, I go
back to this idea of like,
it's our Republic,
if we can keep it.
So as much as I make that
grimaced face, as everyone does,
we have to all figure out
ways to get involved, right?
So if that's running for
your local city council
or being part of
your school board,
if it's a county
commissioner at some level,
it doesn't have to be
the top of the pole
in terms of being President
or Senator or something.
If that's your passion and
you've got the money, great.
But just, we all
have to get involved.
So my scrunchy face
getting involved
is on the national
level, man, it's just,
I think we all know what happens
when people run for office.
Stuff gets yanked out of your
past completely misrepresented
or, you know, you're
imperfect, right?
And so nobody
wants to face that.
I don't have a lot of that so
that's not what anchors me.
It's just the idea of, man,
just being a public person,
always under the microscope.
So that's why I'm
doing a podcast
so that doesn't make any sense.
I love my argument. I'm just
undermined it, it's great.
- Well, former County
Commissioner Bryan Dean Wright,
I appreciate you doing the show
and look forward
to seeing you soon.
Thanks man.
- You betcha.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.